vraiment un plaisir d'être là toujours
aussi un plaisir d'être écoutée par les
jeunes c'est ça nous ça nous a fait
reculer le curseur plusieurs années de
nous revoir nous mène à votre place
quand on a fait votre âge on n'est pas
là pour vous faire la morale pour vous
dire que tout marche bien que c'est
super que c'est magnifique c'est simple
c'est parfait d'accord donc la vie est
quand même quelque chose de complexe à
compliquer tout ce qui est compliqué en
le réduit à des petites choses hein
c'est complexe et un briquet et peut
être que personnellement et ma
génération nous avons eu de la chance de
vivre dans un monde qui est quand même
moins complexe
aujourd'hui en vie la deuxième
transition de complexité vous vous êtes
mis dans ce groupe alors je suis né avec
la tv en noir et blanc on n'a pas à
payer à son âme acheter la télé comme
moi je suivais d'accord en 66 ça fait
deux mois pour vous la tv fonctionner en
tunisie c'est même moi rigole pendant
hans a commencé à 18 ans ou à peu près
voilà ça diffusée quelques petits
programmes pour les enfants etc
puis ça a basculé avec plein de
programmes achetés en france donc ont
été autorisés y avait plein de films
fictions dont on parle très bien
égyptiens n'ont pas comme vous mais qui
nous parlent pas et soutient alors que
nous on a qu'une et donc quand au fait
on était autorisé le mercredi soir on va
rigoler pour parler de ces deux crans la
manger d'après météo dans l'est
pas autre chose donc je suis cette
génération là pour nous je vous parlais
avec je vais mettre l'accent sur quelque
chose de fondamentalement du socle
valeur de notre génération
j'espère que vous allez vous y accrochez
vous aussi parce que le monde change
mais les valeurs de changement donc nous
nous faisons partie de cette génération
qui croit dans leur halle doit au
travail dur je travaillais dur par en
mode agressif travaille dur parce que le
val d'oise paye parce que les fortes m
parce que quand tu travailles bien
content hub ri quand tu t'accroches et
bayas quand la belle aussi l'ascenseur
social
il ya également ce qu'on appelle la
méritocratie on acheté rien ou vous
méritez la chose ce que vous avez bien
travaillé ce que j'avais bien bossé
vous n'avez c'est pas possible car
autrement c'est pratiquement a bien sûr
il ya toujours des gens qui semblent
favoriser matériellement au moins
favorisés mais globalement les gens
partent et c'était la censure sociale
c'est de la classe moyenne c'était des
gens qui bûche et c'était des gens qui
carrière l'école quénu parfois dans le
grand froid
moi j'ai fait mes premières années
d'études parce que mon père et des chefs
de gare
donc il était chef de gare sur les gars
francs pas hier donc il y avait des
minerais dont deux face à deux de fer et
sera donc moi j'ai fait mes premières
études de primaire à karadj et qui
s'appelle aujourd'hui à l'adresse pas du
kef
donc quand on quand je vois aujourd'hui
nos photos d'enfants danser les gens on
dirait qu'on est
europe quand on a fait une année jusque
là dans les montagnes les tours et on
était dans les écoles rurales dit
pourtant on avait exactement la même
qualité d'enseignement que lorsque nous
sommes rentrés dans notre ville natale à
côté du gouvernement donc au fait les
études paye quand on bosse bien mais on
était quand même dans un système
sélectif
ça c'est très important c'est à dire que
devant les peuples et relève la
préhistoire on faisait pas de cours
particuliers ça n'existait pas d'accord
donc on fait des cours particuliers
comme aurifères ont d'abord essayé en
général l'instit le prof
le directeur qui vient prendre les
enfants qui sont moins performants pour
leur donner un soutien scolaire après
l'heure et ça se passait parfois dans la
cour pendant la récréation sous un
olivier olana mais tout le monde avait
la chance d'y aller en acheter rien
excusez moi s'il vous en travers et mon
professeur était mon modèle
nous enseignants et des des gens qui
porté très haut les valeurs même si nous
agresser parce qu'à l'époque on nous
tape est quand même le relatons les
débats verdier alcool dans les droits de
l'enfance
donc je suis un petit peu de cette
génération coriace dur il sait qu'il
faut s'accrocher
donc j'ai fait ces études là je suis
arrivé suis à 100% produit de
l'éducation nationale tunisienne est
très fier de le dire j'espère que vous
êtes très fier de le dire aujourd'hui
si ses fondamentaux
donc j'ai fait plus si sa limite
monsieur mention machin les neet l'école
nationale d'ingénieurs de tunis et quand
on fait pas si l'on fait partie de
lauréats blake lauréat alors quand vous
dire le système sélectif des grandes
écoles vous allez prépare donc on était
en première année à six classes de 40
on est passé en deuxième année à une
classe de trente deux donc j'ai fini
dans une promotion de génie industriel
ajoute dans toute la république
d'accord j'ai fait ses études
d'ingénieur et c'est bien parce qu'au
débat on veut briller au mauvais film on
a fait des métiers beurre on est
minoritaire nous sommes des femmes en a
réussi et on avait les meilleurs scores
m
on est des majors de promotion non mais
passé les gars on ausculte et puis voilà
il fallait comme on allait aux
entretiens les gens convoquer des
cigares sans les entreprises parce
qu'ils venaient chercher les diplômes
est il qu'aujourd'hui les six garçons il
nous appelait pas nous les deux filles
et puis un jour le monsieur chez une
compagnie pétrolière
qu'est-ce qui se passe voir ma fille
elle a commencé à bien des études
d'ingénieur pourquoi vous n'appelez pas
la baci dans cette profonde du rire
d'eux dans le secteur pétrolier mais
convoqué les les gars sont aidés à 3
entretien non on est arrivé au derrière
entretien moi j'ai décroché le boulot et
le plein
donc c'était super comme satisfaction
désir que en termes de compétences et
pas de différence entre 4,5
ça c'est clair maintenant l'outil mais
avant et reconnaître des petites
barrières les sourcils d'autres
personnes font passer
qui me précédait avant donc jeunes hier
exploser sa charge à vous d'y accéder
encore plus dur donc ceci étant en jeu
j'ai fait ma carrière j'ai été recruté
donc de grands coups et j'ai fait la
performance d'être directrice d'une
succursale du plus grand ou petit
musicien qui n'a jamais recruté prévu
une femme comme directrice générale
c'est dommage que je sois la seule dans
toute l'histoire ce groupe là le groupe
poulina j'aimerais bien que parmi les
gens présents dans la salle y aurait
aussi des directrices générales dans ce
groupe parce que c'est pas ce petit fils
donc qu'est-ce qui après effectivement
dans cette saison quand plus folles à
moi j'ai toujours été dans la société
civile parce que j'ai commencé très
jeune et j'adore le travail d'andré
d'autres pubs d'intérêt général mais
avec des études difficiles arrivent et
ariane difficile on laisse un peu de
côté en fait un petit goût de choses
j'ai toujours adhéré là moi je m'appelle
toujours belluschi points coeur parce
que dès qu'il ya quelque chose à faire
il n'y a pas d'argent en appel j'arrive
je suis ici je peux prêter main-forte se
fera un plaisir et à
qu'est ce que ça vous procure simple ça
vous procure un réseau extraordinaire de
naissance vous connaissez d'un plein
plein plein de monde est plein de rendre
dans différents secteurs
si vous êtes dans le textile uniquement
vous allez connaître les gens du textile
de l'équipement sida et quand vous
touchez à la prévention routière de
chine taiwan de sherwood peuvent toucher
aux femmes l'accès au réseau s'élargit
vos horizons s'élargissent et vos
perspectives de développement s'élargit
et perspectives après c'est pas pour
vous ça sert strictement à rien
vous êtes sur votre carrière sur votre
lancée c'est fini la carrière respective
vous avez créé votre entreprise etc
mais il arrive des moments où votre vie
ne signifie rien si vous ne passez pas
la main si vous mettez pas les autres
réellement et donc c'est effectivement
ce qu'on a fait ce que je fais mais avec
beaucoup de la vie extraordinaire dans
du bassin relativement qu'on attribue
par exemple familier de chip depuis 2000
ans l'association qui travaille beaucoup
sur le leadership féminin et qui oeuvre
pour promouvoir les femmes dans les
postes de décision déçoit salariés
qu'elles payent aussi établir son propre
business
y a pas de mauvais qu'il 16 madame
disque qui vient de sortir que nous
avons près qu après carrière après elle
est revenu à des basiques par céder rêve
que c'est un accomplissement ces
magnifiques parce que ça prouve mais de
la valeur parce que ça conflit une
tradition une identité une culture un
pays un peuple c'est important et donc
finalement c'est ça moi je vous retrouve
plus dans le film en gif sg lancer un
nouveau business a fait trois ans une
école primaire fernandes je suis en
train de développer un complexe éducatif
avec des méthodes finlandaise mais c'est
très bien parce que je vois des petits
poussins réduirait la grande place est
magnifique mais ce qui me fait le plus
plaisir c'est de voir de jeunes filles
qui construisent leur business
les a coaché parce qu'elle parte à milan
pour faire des défilés de bijoux de
qualité et cédera qui à vis des
mannequins internationaux parce qu'on
est un défi qui font de larissa au fin
fond de kerouat et qui sont en train de
vendre aux états unis parce qu'on a une
fille dont le papa est décédé dans la
maman est une aline et mentale et la
saur et une handicapée qui fait ses
études à la sorbonne
c'est ça le sens de la vie et c'est ça
les grands changements de la ville j'ai
deux filles j'estime que ma carrière une
loin derrière moi j'ai des figurants
votre âge mais j'ai aussi beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de femmes et de filles
tunisiennes
ils ont besoin de notre énergie de notre
réseautage de notre amitié de notre vrai
à mort pour les porter vers de meilleurs
cieux voici ma mission aujourd'hui